our societies are very interested in
winners but they don't really know what
to do about losers of which there are
always by definition far more for a long
time around success and failure
the chaps tends to be very upbeat we
hear about resilience bouncing back
never surrendering and giving it another
go
but there's only so long this kind of
talk and go on at some point the
conclusion becomes inevitable
things won't work out the political
career isn't going to have a comeback
there'll be no way of getting financed
for the film the novel won't be accepted
by the 32nd publisher the criminal
charges of forever going to take one's
reputation on stuffed up big time
where is responsibility for success and
failure lie
nowadays squarely with the individual
concerned that's why failure isn't just
hard as it's always been
it's a catastrophe there's no
metaphysical consolation no possibility
of appealing to an idea of bad luck
no one to blame but oneself no wonder
suicide rates climb exponentially one
societies become modern and start to
hold people profoundly responsible for
their biographies meritocracy is turn
failure from a misfortune to an
unbridgeable existential verdict on the
state of one's soul but not all
societies and errors have seen success
and failure in such a stark light in
ancient greece another rather remarkable
possibility quite ignored by our own era
was envisaged you could be good
and yet fail to keep this idea at the
front of the collective imagination
the ancient Greeks developed a
particular art form tragic drama
they put on huge festivals which all the
citizens were expected to attend to act
out stories of a Pauling often grizzly
failure
people would seem to break a minor law
will make a hasty decision or sleep with
the wrong person and the result was
ignominy and death yet what happened was
shown to be to a large extent in hands
of what the Greeks called fate or the
gods
it was the Greeks poetic way of saying
that things often work out in random
ways according to dynamics that simply
don't reflect the merits of the
individuals concern in the poetic
the philosopher Aristotle to find the
key ingredients of tragedy
the hero of a tragedy should be a decent
person better than average often
highborn but prone to making small
mistakes as we all do at the start it
may not be obvious that it's an error
they're making but by an unfortunate
chain of events for which they're not
wholly to blame this small mistake leads
to a catastrophe a tragedy is the
sympathetic morally complex account of
how good people can end up in disaster
situations
it's the very opposite of today's
tabloid newspaper or social media sphere
where the mob rushes to make judgments
on those who slipped up
Aristotle thought is extremely important
that people see tragic works on a
regular basis to counter their otherwise
strong inclinations to judge in to
moralize a good tragedy should for
Aristotle inspire both pity and fear
pity for the tragic hero based on an
understanding of how easy it is to make
the slip that leads to a disaster and
fear for oneself as one realizes how
open our lives are two careering out of
control all of us could quite quickly
come apart if ever events chose to test
us
tragedy is meant to be a corrective too
easy judgment
it exists a counter on natural instincts
to admire only the successful to spurn
all those who fail and to dismiss
unfortunates as losers
we're currently very uncomfortable
around the idea of a good person not
succeeding
we'd rather say that they weren't good
at all that embrace a far more
disturbing and less well publicized
thought that in fact the world is very
unfair but without the idea of tragedy
we make existence for everyone far
crueler and far more judgmental than it
really need be
it's time to look back in history to
recover an extremely important idea